field yates of espn.com had access to
all of the official nfl management
council salary cap number somebody gave
those to him yesterday he posted them on
twitter and the team with the lowest
amount
of cap space and i in all the years i've
been doing this chris i've never seen a
team with this little cap space the
kansas city chiefs currently have
177
now before we go any further for those
of you watching on tv you'll see the
texans listed at the top with 49.2
million keep in mind and
um
this was pointed out by aaron wilson of
the houston chronicle the houston texans
number is inflated because they got a
bunch of deals that haven't officially
been done yet that number is going to
plummet when some of the deals that
haven't been signed or there hasn't been
a physical or they haven't otherwise hit
the cap that number will drop but for
the chiefs it's not dropping it can't
drop
177 chris that is as tight as i said as
any team i've ever seen pressed against
the salary cap
yeah no it really is i mean i think you
know we've seen some teams maybe you
know dabble in the negatives for a day
or two a few days here and there uh but
you know these are common
very long no you can't do it for very
long you got to settle up you got to
settle up at the end of the day i'm not
aware of being able to be in the
negatives you've got to be on the right
side of the cap at the end of the day
you can be negative throughout the day
but by 4 pm eastern you got to be on the
right side of the cap or there is i
don't know what the consequence is
because i don't think anybody's ever
done that i don't think everybody's ever
done it either no i i was more referring
to like before the year start the league
year starts things like that you see the
numbers and the negatives and everything
like that but hey these are problems
that yeah the wealthy have when you're
wealthy you're about to put a huge
diamond ring on your you know your ring
finger your championship ring finger
there's a lot of good players on that
football team i mean it's not a shock i
mean you know we've seen this happen to
the seattle seahawks we saw the denver
broncos have problems with the cap after
they won the super bowl you have
superstar players free agents become in
demand and of course the elephant in the
room is they have a quarterback that we
all know is going to be the highest paid
player in the history of the sport and
they don't have a lot of wiggle room and
the biggest thing i think mike with
anything with any of this and what we
always see
other than the new england patriots
everybody else does this is they hold on
to players of their super bowl teams too
long they can't cut the cord oh that was
a special team oh that was a special
group in the locker room so people keep
that lifeline a lot alive a little bit
longer now i don't know who the casualty
should be in kansas city i've got a few
names we'll discuss here in a minute but
you know when you look at who's being
paid you know other than this one guy
aka sami watkins everybody else is you
know a huge contributor to the football
team as far as the guys that are making
major money uh and
and a knock to the salary cap
well and before we get to watkins there
is an easy way to take some of the
bigger contracts and create cap space
frank clark for example he's got a 19.3
million dollar cap number they can take
his 12 million dollar salary let's just
say they take 10 million of it and leave
them with a 2 million salary they can
spread the 10 million over the next four
years two and a half million per year
and they create seven and a half million
in cap space now so they can do that in
a heartbeat they can do that in a second
and it doesn't affect frank clark at all
it gets him all of his money now or at
least it guarantees all of it now and i
think it may already be guaranteed
anyway so it's no big deal if he's
willing to do it sometimes guys aren't
willing to do it but if clark is willing
to do it they can create seven and a
half million in 2020 cap space with the
stroke of a pen there are other guys who
fall into that same category tyron
mathews deal could be restructured
you've got guys like eric fisher you've
got guys like travis kelsey now some
guys will have to be extended because
we've got several players like matthew
and fisher and kelsey who have only two
years left on their deal so you don't
have multiple years to spread that
number out and get the lowest possible
cap number now
so that can be done and they can easily
create cap space there but that's
kicking the can and you have to account
for those dollars in the future
watkins sandy watkins has a 21 million
cap number 14 million dollar base salary
this year if they trade him or if they
cut him that 14 million goes away
forever chris and that's why he
continues to be in jeopardy
yes uh you know
it's really odd really to this point
that we haven't heard
much rumors or talks about it or
anything you know i don't know do they
want to try to restructure a guy like
sammy watkins extend his contract to
then maybe lessen the number you know he
is talented we know that we saw that in
the playoffs we saw that in the super
bowl but at the end of the day you know
the best ability is availability
everybody always says and sami watkins
is not available a lot hasn't been
available a lot during his time in
kansas city and hasn't produced the
numbers and the effect on opposing
defenses that i would imagine they want
let alone mike they got a guy in the
wings and nicole hardman who's similar
in theory who's a guy that can catch a
slant and take it 50 yards or beat
somebody deep for a 70-yard bomb down
the sideline whatever it may be so
there's wiggle room and i'm not saying
nicole hardman sammy watkins yet he has
a little work to do there but uh the
sami watkins thing is the the biggest
one you look at as far as players that
could be a cap casualty that would make
a lot of sense and you understand it but
i think there's probably reluctance
because the offense got them to the
super bowl it's special that's why they
won the super bowl sammy made a big play
down the sideline and it's hard to cut
that cord to go okay let's find somebody
else new when you know you just had a
proven commodity super bowl winner
yeah sammy made a big play in a smart
play where we had he had seen devonta
adams in the nfc championship game how
he got by richard sherman on a deep
route and sammy watkins did the same
thing in a key moment and and uh and
generated a big gain watkins when he
signed his contract chris remember we
had this debate a couple of years ago
comparing watkins contract to odell
beckham's contract my argument was and i
think i brought you around on this
watkins has a better contract because it
was only three years and it was it was
from scratch there was none of this new
money stuff it was a free agent contract
they paid him a ton of money and what
they've gotten out of it is 519
receiving yards in 2018 which doesn't
justify 14 million for 2020 and they got
673 yards out of him for 2019. that
doesn't justify 14 million dollars for
2020. means something's gonna happen
with watkins and i think for now chris
they're gonna wait to see
my guess would be at this stage of the
season the off season
let's see what happens in the draft
let's see if there's a team that's got
its eyes on on a cd lam or jerry judy
and doesn't get him maybe going into the
second day of the draft there's a
willingness to do something and maybe
sammy watkins takes less money or
renegotiates gets a long term deal and
still has 14 million this year but you
know he gets less in future years
there's something i think that could
happen almost like the randy moss trade
of 2007 that brought him from the
raiders to the patriots that happened
during the draft this feels like the
kind of trade that can happen during the
draft or they get through the draft they
haven't traded him and they just they
just say see you later sammy watkins
yeah they very easily could do that or
you know they're sitting there at 32 and
a receiver that they valued and looked
at and go oh we thought this was the
first or second best receiver in the
draft and here he is available to us at
32. you know maybe they take them you
know so there's a lot of options here
you're right i think they're going to
let this play out it's going to be the
the long play for sure but i don't think
there's going to be a huge mar you're
right if anybody trades for sammy
watkins there's not going to be like a
huge market they're not going to get a
huge uh be able to command huge draft
picks and assets that way especially
with the injury history and the
production that you just mentioned it's
underwhelming but the big thing is there
is still talent and i think that's
probably what kansas city sees and
that's probably why they're not gonna if
it does come to a trade just sell them
down the river for nothing because all
you gotta do is look at the guy when he
is healthy you know the afc championship
game the super bowl you know he made
game-changing plays he's got
game-changing ability and you know when
he is healthy that's why he was a top 10
pick now he hasn't lived up to that but
you know it's a tough decision for
kansas city it really is because this
offense has made this team go and of
course you want to support mahomes with
weapons
now what the chiefs are doing they are
taking full advantage of the rights they
have under sammy watkins contract to
squat on him at a time when you know if
he had been on the open market two weeks
ago he may have landed somewhere and
gotten a nice payday and he may get
thrust back onto the open market after
refusing to take a pay cut maybe as we
get closer to the season and i'm
mentioning all this because yesterday
you and i agreed that the panthers
screwed cam newton by holding him as
long as they did how do we feel about
the chiefs exercising their rights here
with sami watkins to to keep him on the
payroll knowing that none of this is
guaranteed there's no trigger in there
that forces them to move him by a
certain date and every contract needs to
have those in every year to prevent this
kind of thing from happening but the
chiefs are acting within their rights
and it could be that tammy watkins ends
up getting screwed on this chris
well yeah there's no doubt but you know
i do think it's different than the cam
newton situation first off cam newton
was like the face of that franchise for
the last nine years you know he was an
mvp brought them to the super bowl you
know he's done a lot of good things in
the community not to say sammy watkins
isn't great in the community and a great
guy but you just mentioned you know he
doesn't have the same leverage or you
know roots in the city but certainly
doesn't have the same leverage as a cam
newton to complain when we just talk
about he's being paid like he's one of
the best receivers in football but yet
the production has been
below the middle class of football at
the wide receiver position so from that
standpoint alone he needs to be grateful
to the kansas city chiefs for that too
to go okay hey i mean man you gave me
money you've given me a lot of money i
haven't produced for you i'm willing to
sit here and let you figure things out
to where maybe i come back and make that
money maybe we make another deal and
keep moving forward or maybe i get
traded i just think it's a little
different uh as far as the cam newton
situation
you know it's funny i don't know where
the line is but i agree with you cam
newton is on one side of it where i
think they kept him longer than they
should have with sammy watkins they're
fully within their rights the chiefs are
to keep him and fortunately we don't
have to make a tougher call for somebody
who is closer to that line of what is
and what isn't right when it comes to a
team operating within its rights under
the contract that the player signed if
watkins gets traded where do you want to
see him you're always looking for more
targets for aaron rodgers in green bay
is that a guy you'd like to see wearing
green and gold
oh
that would be one of the teams right
towards the top of the list no question
you know again like i love devonte adams
i like lazard uh you know the other big
receiver but he's like a number three
they need another guy in my opinion if
they want to keep up with the san
francisco 49ers of the world again if
they get into the playoffs and have to
get in some sort of shootout you know i
don't think they were capable of playing
those games unless it was a you know a
bad defense so yes watkins to green bay
watkins to philadelphia i think can make
a lot of sense you know again i'll just
go back to our combine conversation with
howie roseman he talked about all they
wanted to do is you know support carson
wentz but they have their cap cap issues
too and i don't think they've been able
to make the moves or find the support or
weapons for carson once yet either i
mean i know they got the draft too but
that would be another place i would look
at for sure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports